[Musique]
on est confronté souvent à des cas de
harcèlement des harcèlements qui vont
avoir leur leur origine dans
l'établissement scolaire mais qui
prennent de l'ampleur parce qu'il se
développe ensuite sur les réseaux
sociaux si il prend autant d'ampleur de
nos jours et s'il est aussi grave en
conséquences puisque malheureusement les
cas de suicide sont très nombreux c'est
parce qu'il il se nourrit des des
réseaux sociaux et de l'usage qui peut
être fait des
téléphones malheureusement quand les
signes sont visibles ça va plutôt être
du repli sur soi de une personne qui
s'isole qui qui va changer de
comportement c'est que le harcèlement
est déjà bien installé et que les
troubles sont là et et durable moi je je
préfère qu'on travaille même avant que
ces signes apparaissent je dis souvent
que les jeunes entre eux discutent
beaucoup et qu'il voient plein de choses
sur les réseaux sociaux ils sont
plusieurs et quand quand quelqu'un
constate que un de ses camarades est
souvent visé et qu'il y a des choses pas
bien qui se passent et ben il faut agir
vite je donnais beaucoup de numéros
verts sur les sur le le harcèlement et
je me suis rendu compte que nos jeunes
ont parfois une difficulté à prendre
leur téléphone et à composer ce numéro
je sais pas c'est une crainte assez
assez récurrente chez les jeunes donc
maintenant ce que je leur dis c'est que
les réseaux sociaux c'est un côté
négatif ça peut servir à harceler mais
c'est un côté extrêmement positif que ça
peut permettre de prendre beaucoup
d'information il existe un site qui
s'appelle stop harcèlement et ce site
peut les aider à libérer leurs paroles
ils peuvent toujours faire un appel 17
prendre des renseignements auprès d'un
commissariat ou d'une association d'Aid
aux victimes tout le monde est capable
de les aider y compris leur
établissement
[Musique]
scolair